it takes patience to solve a riddle and
apparently for paul dano it also takes a
lot of patience to play the riddler the
batman is one of the most highly
anticipated films to come out in 2022.
there's a lot riding on the film as it
shows the departure warner brothers is
taking with the dc extended universe for
starters there is a new caped crusader
in town played by robert pattinson he
takes over the role from ben affleck who
played the dark knight for several years
avalak will still have a role to play
seeing how he has an appearance in the
upcoming flash movie that same movie
will also see michael keaton return to
the role he helped popularize who hasn't
donned the cowl since 1992's batman
returns but while the flash film will
likely be a swan song for the actors
patton since just getting warmed up from
catwoman to penguin we're seeing new
iterations of these characters like
never before especially when it comes to
the movie's main big bad the riddler
dano is an exciting actor to see in a
superhero film after incredible turns in
movies like there will be blood and
prisoners he brought the same level of
dedication to the riddler as he's done
in his previous roles but the level of
commitment may take some viewers by
surprise
i've been trying to reach you
usually when you hear about a movie shot
requiring over 100 takes to get right
it's generally at the behest of the
director filmmakers like stanley kubrick
and alfred hitchcock have wanted to
ensure that a scene looks just right on
film often pushing actors and crew
members to the limit however the reverse
happened on the set of the batman in an
in-depth discussion of the superhero
movie with the hollywood reporter
director matt reeves spoke about how
paul dano requested numerous takes for
one particular scene in the film there's
a sequence where riddler is by himself
in a room taking iphone footage to
display his madness reeves estimated
that it took roughly 200 takes to get it
right and that many of them were a
result of daniel wanting to try
different variations reeves recalled
daniel's behavior on set saying he goes
okay let me try one where i'm off camera
and i stick my head in let me try one
where i'm already sitting there he's
directing this one-person play on an
iphone it was the giddiness that really
got to me calling out the passing time
like he was a game show host he was so
inventive and creative he's also very
critical of himself it turned out to be
a path worth pursuing the sequence
became one of the most chilling in the
entire film which is really saying
something the batman is a dark complex
picture and riddler is the perfect
antagonist to go up against this
particular version of the dark knight
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
that riddler scene isn't the only moment
that got some tweaks during production
speaking with denim geek robert
pattinson discussed the scene in which
batman goes up against a gang of goons
wearing white face makeup
the hell are you supposed to be
according to pattinson the scene was
supposed to play out a little
differently than it ended up being in
the final movie he said how it was
initially staged was the guy says who
are you and batman says i'm vengeance
and then beats everybody up but the
actor apparently felt it would be more
impactful to switch some things up
explaining i said to rob alonso second
unit director and supervising stunt
coordinator i really want to say it into
the guy's face when he's basically dead
it just goes to show that following
actors instincts about their characters
can sometimes lead to positive
i outcomes you
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you